peu
[Musique]
regardez bien ceci est pourtant une
plage celle de sainte anne la palud dans
le finistère une plage transformé par
les vacanciers en un vaste parking
nous avons vu trois mille véhicules
venir ainsi s'approprier l'espace
généralement réservé ailleurs aux jeux
de plage ou aux baigneurs
[Musique]
le moment on n'a aucune solution étant
donné qu'on n'a pas de nos moyens sont
pas suffisantes pour les voitures ya
déjà les routes réservées limité à la
vitesse et tous ils envahissent les
plages on n'a qu'à leur donner les
plages et puis garder les routes pour
nous soumettre à bronzer
[Musique]
certains trouvent une facilité et
justement se déplacer la voiture sur la
plage et d'impossibilité pour
déshabiller pour cliquer de tous ces
pratiques avaient les enfants turbulents
mené tout le début nos affaires c'est un
point de repère à les voitures ça au
point de repère les gens disent tiens on
a gardé notre portée à leur bien-être
servier plein c'est toujours mieux
d'avoir un accident mais occident graf
y'en a pas eu heureusement
mais dont les craintes toujours tous les
étés
[Musique]
on semaine ici moi c'est ce que je fais
on vient ici bonbons s'arrête ça va ce
qu'ils font du rodéo c'est bien les gens
qui critiquent
[Musique]